all them means nothing they're manmade
ideology once I realized the stuff they
teaching me made no sense they got out
of nowhere and they just that oh he's
the
best and then they make second wave
feminism third wave this that they make
like a big
ideology when you have no guidance
Allah for example feminism started
defending
their basic right which is as a normal
human being they should have basic right
basic woman should be educated no doubt
woman has a right to inherent the woman
has a right to to to to to to to what
they call it to to to to choose whatever
way better yes to choose whoever husband
she's happy with you understand so it's
her right you know however when you try
to rectify and deal with oppression
without the guidance of the Creator by
therefore you would end up with another
oppression Subhan Allah so you had
feminism then you had red movement
they're trying to to reut this extremism
extremist ideology of feminism however
because they don't have a guidance from
the Creator they end up for it's another
extremism Allah that's why battle should
not be refuted with another
battle so there is no way for us to do
with in order for us to do with every
oppression and every
problems except we need in order for us
to deal with it correctly you need Islam
you understand you need Islam
Islam has solution everything
chanity
Shar doesn't have Shar which is the
government must follow dealing with its
people dealing with uh inner Affairs or
outer Affairs political yeah economy
all of that doesn't have that that's
right but Islam that's what Islam is a
way of life you know that's what they
don't understand yeah Islam is the way
of life Islam look Islam teaches you how
to relationship with your
creator look he has the thing for you
it's much easier Islam has solution for
tell you how to deal how to to worship
Allah
then how to deal with your parents how
to deal with your wife how to deal with
your children how to deal with your
neighbors how to deal with environment
how to deal with animals how to deal
with enemies how to deal with friends
how to deal with cousins how to do with
everything how to do with even tyranny
oppression yeah how to do with
oppression Islam that's what Islam why
Islam is valid sh Islam what is valid
every place at every time why because
Islam came with the general principles
for example
there's you see you don't harm yourself
don't harm others this you can apply it
to every
situation
likewise rep away the evil take prison
over bring benefit bringing benefit but
this General is not ml there's
restriction there sometimes uh bringing
about goodness it takes over pushing
away the evil so of course there's
conditions to it and so on you know and
um also removing evil with a greater
evil is not permissible you see likewise
the principle what leads to evil it's
evil like one
person yeah know for example bringing
singers who glamorize and propagate and
glorify criminals lifestyle should even
invite them to sing because
why so you are allowing these singers
Allah guide them to brainwash children a
person yeah promoting them person might
say is going to affect him yeah but
you're not sure you cannot guarante for
every young boy or young girl that this
singer will affect their lifestyle
that's why principle Subhan Allah for
example life crime in in in Britain it's
an epidemic it's happening every day
yeah money put on netf
thisal it's Madness money out theet of
course as long it
money if it makes money it makes sense
that's that's their
Universal that's why
maity that's why majority times those
who are very hostile to Islam those who
are in power generally speaking not
every person power is very generally
speaking that because why Islam go
against the agenda alcohol is Haram
drugs is Haram
prostitutes institution is Haram you
know porn yeah and so it's Haram har but
they making money out of it and that's
why cap capitalism is based upon but
Islam Allah cares about his creation you
see so Islam came not to destroy the
people to protect the people but if the
arrogant and the tyrants trying to stop
Islam to be pred the Jihad comes
in economy is based on is backed by har
money look happed 2009 the crunch
because what
recession they lost their har money and
they prining har yeah yeah subh that's
why you know Islam Islam is is is is the
solution for mankind not Christianity
Christianity you know like I said they
have no Shar you know I mean they had
Shar at that time but I'm talking about
Christianity now the the the poor
Christianity likewise
Judaism they allow to bribe you they
allow to do other things but between
themselves they allow to Justice they
should not bribe each other they do to
other people yes if been translated in
English there's a lot of cre stuff about
non-jewish they're like a dogs they're
like you know it's
crazy Jewish is not a belief he's a tri
thing so you cannot born you must born
as a Jewish
person like Islam you have you can
choose to become Muslim so so Judaism
they have a tribe with God God only
cares about
them that's why going back when you look
at the people that hate Islam especially
women
yeah subh in look
go go are not humans they are a beasts
all children of go are
animal even the best of go should be
should all be killed see
that yeah of course yeah it you may
violate but not marry a non girl Gentile
girl or boy girls are in a state of from
birth look this one's even crazy and you
may have sex with a
child as long as the child is less than
9 years old that's what they do in the
tunnels killing babies and children even
the best of Guam should be
killed and was what promoted and
what yeah so you know one thing before
for you know Allah even the women that
are against Islam I are ignorant of
Islam or they like to be they like to be
humiliated or they picking truth no not
picking truth I'm talking about woman
that against against
Islam a Muslim cuz Islam respects you
Islam protects you Islam protects you
being to be used as as like a public
toilet you understand Islam make you
human being so want to see who woman are
against Islam are Islam they been
brainwashed and can teach them or they
like to be
[Applause]
humiliated they coming from me
what protect us from
them that's it goes back to the other
one
or when Allah told a woman to cover
herself not because Allah hat her Allah
loves to for her to be protected
you know when Allah told the believer
the woman to protect
herself about capitalis capitalism they
use the woman for what capital adver
advertise a car what car has to do with
women to ad advertise toothpaste what
toothpaste has to do with wom go to
your psychologically used to push you to
drive a nice car you get a nice girl is
it yeah again he see subh Allah
psychology yeah when you Chas the you're
chasing
yeah hence the word the American dream
and all of these things I mean don't get
me wrong having a good woman righteous
is
a said this D is beautiful and the most
beautiful thing about this dun having a
good
wife understand